walk him to this video playing finger
slip from Denmark okay so much for the
night off 3h three yeah you can probably
playable without being worse just go for
normal development but now he's got this
one okay let's let's try to think about
this for a moment okay here at least he
cannot easily play the form okay he can
play deform it takes the canvas could be
dangerous Bishop before the special g5
this kind of porn sacrifices some
unknown theoretically they can can be
very tricky but
but can I allow the five it's not it
that's not looking too great yeah or
maybe a must I don't really I don't
really want to take 1945 losers
instantly be sure before Bishop g5 was
very dangerous now ok you can go d5 now
I play Bishop d7 and I can always hope
for my usual bishops that but it's not
it's not terribly greatest this piece on
the seven at the moment
yeah maybe I can play like that look to
c 8 and do something on the queenside
but why does sort Nina in good shape you
can play mary e 5 I don't know if I can
take on g5 my intrest angle maybe be
five before you if he goes in five now I
have this Bishop at five intermediate
move which might be might be useful okay
this before i move or is it just
weakening yet is weakening that's clear
actually but yeah i still need to get
something going here rookie a circle k 6
queen bee to should be okay i don't see
a good discovery by the night i hope i'm
not overlooking something there
maybe efficiently five next I mean the
special bond is seven is good long job
okay we can't forget about that because
it didn't happen this should be five
here may be accessable better be five I
can take on a age okay this is useless
and here I thought that he does not have
a good discovery by the noid let's hope
this judgment wasn't totally for him
this that would be one actually ah this
was love in this was the son this was
one of the cases where I played move
rather quickly without really realizing
what i was doing i always keep
criticizing that but sometimes of course
it happens to me as well yeah this looks
it looks shaky this position
once got very very nicely centralized
pieces it really looks like there might
be something but I don't see it at the
moment
yeah it's taking us time route be one I
need to play Quincy to where this is at
least easy don't need to waste any time
on that
yeah I know some sort of e 5 or maybe
just yeah but it's not really great yeah
you 5d takes there is no great move for
him
why is taking lots of time here it's
almost like my time management ya need
to do here yeah and the question is can
I avoid the draw I can go to h6 and to
age 5 that looks risky it really does
but now that he has spent so much time I
don't want to give them an easy
repetition and it's not not clear that
this is super convincing for him maybe
it is yeah move like that I was just
thinking about it just attacking here
threatening Bishop f6 and hoping for
them the week Becca rank um I wonder if
I can take one age three actually
he's not very well coordinated okay I
try that I try that it's it's the thing
is take stakes there is not G for the
knight on f3 is hanging ok it's doing
something entirely different taking them
ok
I that I didn't didn't really consider
it all not interesting hmm 94 maybe
takes that I can take on g4 and on c3
miss Kaoru could be seven but I've got
think of it okay I need to play honey to
play move and that's totally crazy here
okay I thought I can take one year for
now Knight takes Queen age three and
okay now that's that's dangerous now you
can take on d6 but that's also this one
hanging ok check every time I have some
checks yeah but not sure if I have more
check check if you're going to eat tool
cannot take you far though I can play 95
at the end Jack maybe this Queen h12
your form check check
can take be one clap at this check for
us this better check check check yeah it
was just just um I don't know fistfight
with no gloves at the end no idea what
was going on there I mean this wasn't
this wasn't a total gamble I really
thought this might be a move because he
is so uncoordinated like that just
because this is interesting this is
hanging on f3 let's start with that and
if he moves in the night let's say here
for example there is there is this and I
couldn't really i cannot calculate this
I mean but it looks it looks dangerous
than these cheques de force hanging see
three years checked he's got rooked be
eight though okay I couldn't assess it
but I thought it might be worth a shot
it seems that white has rupee eight
though pointed out by the engine yeah
that's a good move yeah that's a good
move so it could have taken but in fact
that the computer gives Queenie 7s even
better winning for why totally winning
so I went here which probably is not
working Bishop g7 is what the computer
wants to do okay okay yeah 30 seconds
Bishop g7 okay I thought I could
actually just take with the Queen
because c3 is hanging but there is a
there's a problem with it yes rook be
three okay yeah yeah these this kind of
moves I mean there are tough there are
tough I cannot take b3 now because rupee
eight is completely winning Jack leading
to a checkmate so yeah I have no movie
relief this is strapped so Bishop g7 was
winning it took
and now after this HG is still winning
it seems that this is a draw according
to the computer I don't know why exactly
but yeah there are even just this this
kind of movies even in the position very
strict very strange stuff and its sequel
material believe it or not yeah okay
well what happened I took here now we
can take on g4 which is good for white
okay well that's computer chess it took
them and now we are we are we have an
equal position yeah yeah and 95 is the
best move okay but still equal after
Korea King you too but he played to this
and this is winning na home for black oh
that's very nice actually the computer
finds a quicker quicker made with rook
c2 yeah that's a very cute move this is
checkmate an immediate made and figures
him check check check check check make
very nice yeah so not the most correct
game but it was a good fight hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching